entre les projections les restrictions
et l'espoir des vaccins le regard ce
soir de rémi quirion scientifique en
chef du québec monsois monsieur clients
oui bon choix
c'est une bonne nouvelle je présume bien
sûr cette avancée pour les vaccins selon
vous a qu'un ces vaccins seront
inaccessibles au canada on a fait des
progrès très très rapide au cours des
derniers mois c'est vraiment assez
exceptionnel je pense bien que dans des
bus le premier 1er 2 3 mois de l'année
20 21
les vaccins devrait disponible au canada
et est ce que les commandes qu'on ne
fait que le gouvernement a fait jusqu'à
maintenant est ce que tout ça est
suffisant selon vous par jour premier
temps ça va être suffisant pour les
personnes que l'on devra lac signer l'an
priorité bien sûr comme les travailleurs
de la santé les personnes âgées les
personnes non plus à risque qui ont
d'autres pathologies
donc on devrait en avoir suffisamment
pour les vacciner on n'aura pas
suffisamment de doses au point de départ
pour vacciner tout le monde mais au
cours de l'année si tout va bien et les
juges n de production de vaccins mais
tiennent à une cadence très accéléré on
devrait en avoir suffisamment là pour
vacciner la grande majorité des
canadiens une vaccination massive
ce serait à peu près à quel moment dans
l'année 2021 selon vous je pense pas ça
vous promettre plus été début de
l'automne la pour avoir ça prend des
protocoles assez assez spéciaux pour ces
vaccins ont besoin de vaccination deux
fois bien sûr l'égard des températures
très froides et suffisent avoir
suffisamment de doses aussi là pour
avoir une réaction une destination très
très large
donc je pense ça va être plutôt l'a été
et est au top mais encore une fois c'est
très rapide l'eau dans le monde de la
recherche développement de vaccins on
n'a jamais vu des dd des résultats aussi
rapide qu est ce que vous pensez des
nouvelles projections des autorités
fédérales aujourd'hui qui illustre une
situation qui semble très inquiétant
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
oui c'est ce que c'était et et keita et
c'est pas une éco canada le
malheureusement peut-être qu'on pourrait
dire monde vu et on voit des flambées de
nombre de corps un peu partout à travers
le monde la même dans des régions des
pays qui va pas été très affecté au
printemps comme en grèce par exemple on
voit des augmentations en suisse
beaucoup d'augmentation même en suède
qui finalement avait été beaucoup plus
relax là on voit maintenant qu'il ya
aussi des des restrictions qui ont été
posées par le gouvernement la balle a
donc cet ex convoi au canada on le voit
dans beaucoup de pays à travers le monde
ce qui est un peu différent de la
première phase la pandémie ou au
printemps c'était beaucoup plus
localisée au printemps à montréal bien
sûr très très affectée mais moins en
région
plusieurs provinces manitoba l'alberta
très peu touché maintenant le nombre de
capes par habitant par capita est énorme
en au manitoba et en alberta donc oui
c'est assez inquiétant et je pense qu'on
connaît quand même peu l'arcep l'on ne
pas le vexer encore malheureusement mais
moins de contacts distanciation sociale
les masses laver les mains
c'est ce qu'il faut faire au cours des
prochaines semaines et on a senti un
message donc très clair qu'il fallait
réduire ses contacts dans les
projections mais dans le message
également au tant à ottawa qu'à toronto
aujourd'hui je sais pas si je dois faire
des comparaisons mais je vous pose quand
même la question est ce que la stratégie
québécoise qui portait beaucoup sur les
annonces pour le temps des fêtes hier et
appropriée selon vous oui je pense je
pense que oui c'est certain que c'est
des situations toujours très très
compliqué difficile mais ça fait quand
même plusieurs mois maintenant qu'on est
dans ce genre de de pandémie là avec des
restrictions on arrive à la période du
temps des fêtes
donc je pense que deux d'abord en en
prévision de noël quelques jours une
semaine où vraiment il ya moins de
contacts une semaine après
elle aussi je pense que c'est quand même
une bonne décision il faut maintenir une
certaine cohésion de notre société il
faut aussi portent pas décourager tout
le monde passait succès la phase 2 c'est
plus difficile du côté du côté santé
mentale je dirais la 1e donc d'avoir au
moins la possibilité de voir les
personnes qu'on aime les membres de
familles dans des conditions assez
précises et des petits groupes ce succès
pas le temps de faire des gros gros
party lh2 vraiment très peu sur peu de
jours je pense quand même la bonne
décision là pour garder un certain
morale de notre de notre société
mais comme le disait monsieur legault
premier ministre respecté son contrat
moral haut il demande à tous les
québécois de respectives pour le temps
des fêtes
en ontario le premier ministre ford dit
qu'on ne peut pas m il a dit aujourd'hui
on peut pas mettre l'école à risque on
peut pas mettre les personnes âgées à
risque les résidences pour personnes
âgées à risque et on ne peut pas prendre
le risque de surcharger nos hôpitaux
est-ce que son approche et les plus
strictes au plus prudente c'est
intéressant comme comme question
certains cols l'ontario avait été moins
strict que le québec ou au printemps
dernier maintenant le nombre de cas qui
est plus grand qu'au québec présentement
c'est ce que la population est plus
grandes aussi donc je pense qu'il décide
de receler répartissent le contrôle sa
majorité perdue au québec oui on
aimerait baissé beaucoup plus que le
nombre de cas qu'on a à chacun chaque
jour mais quand même on est quand même
relativement stables depuis plusieurs
plusieurs semaines on espère que ça va
ça va rester comme ça là mais je pense
qu on note quand même assez bon contrôle
la situation ici au québec si bien sûr
encore une fois tous les québécois
respectent les consignes la santé
publique
il ya des gens qui ne croient pas que la
coved 19 et une vraie crise ou qui ne
veulent pas avoir vaccin car ce sera
disponible est-ce que ça ça vous
inquiète
oui c'est un extrait ça nous inquiète
s'inquiètent les chercheurs les
scientifiques là parce que je pense
qu'on devrait vraiment aider les humains
on est on fait partie d'une société dont
kate - individuelle et cela est de
penser que si nous on on croit que les
actions en cours plus ou moins que ça
fonctionne mais penser que si on prend
comme peut-être qu'on peut effectuer
quelqu'un d'autre l'a donc à bas rhin un
esprit que de bien commun finalement là
et c'est certain que ça c'est ça a été
affectée depuis depuis quelques mois où
plusieurs personnes ont commencé à dire
bah moi j'y crois pas vraiment pour
toutes sortes de raisons là mais je
pense qu'on va devoir nous comme
chercheur dans tous les secteurs pas
seulement la santé publique mais pour
les deux séances de recherche des
quelques de se faire vacciner contre le
virus un virus qui quand même très
agressif ça c'est bien pensante bien
comment ils devoir de société si on veut
merci beaucoup pour cette analyse et
réflexion monsieur peillon ce soir
plaisir merci bien bonne soirée